hey guys it is the servants of may my
name is Jess McDonald and you're
watching the predominantly gaming
sometimes too I was focused show games
what news a few more star wars
battlefront details have dropped today
including the fact that the game will
not feature any iron sights mode for
guns dice exec Patrick buck told OXM
that the game will not include iron
sights even though it's a staple of the
battlefield series Park explains there
are no Ironside skin star wars on the
ordinary blasters you have scopes on
some rifles but there are no iron sights
previous battlefront games also omitted
iron sights and buck added that combat
deviation from battlefield with a
deliberate move on their part in the
hopes of keeping battlefront unique
ignoring the fact that their names share
seven letters I guess in other news it's
been confirmed that a TS TS or chicken
walkers will be playable so at least you
can squash your foes like about us
between your bouts of shooting from the
hip like an Ian poor stormtrooper former
EA CEO John Ricca Telo has had a bunch
of nice things to say about the ps4 at
the GamesBeat summit the ex EA exact
said that with Sony's gamer focused
approach they quote [ __ ] nailed it
and they deserved the victory that
victory of course being their apparent
win against Microsoft her Rick Otello
criticized for focusing on entertainment
beyond gaming and trying to compete with
Apple ultimately he blamed Microsoft too
unfocused execution for a smaller degree
of success Microsoft themselves have
continued to stress that the console
sales race is a marathon and not a
sprint at presents more than twenty two
point three million ps4s have been sold
finally there are Batman Arkham Knight
spoilers in this last story so if you
don't want to hear any tune out now for
those who do we found out that girl's
identity contained in the $40 dlc path
is a story expansion that lets you play
as Batgirl and today Rocksteady have
revealed the secret identity of them
steer
brunette while many different characters
have worn the mask of that girl Arkham
Knight director Septon Hill tweeted out
I can confirm it is indeed Barbara
Gordon that's the daughter of Gotham
Police Commissioner James Gordon if you
need to brush up on your bat law in the
Batgirl DLC called a matter of family
you'll visit a whole new location and
that's about everything we know about
it's so far let me know down in the
comments if you think it's too soon to
call the winner for the console war or
not or if you just don't care you can
hedge against what we've got stories on
the legend of zelda for wii u's release
and rock stars dance on GTA 5 mods that
is everything I've got for you today be
sure to leave me your thoughts in the
comments and pop back same time tomorrow
for the five best stories of the whole
gaming week